this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much for joining us today
my name is tony bronco and i work
alongside dr zachary stancil who's the
usda hunt germplasm curator and i wanted
to tell you a little bit about our work
and why we wanted to host this uh
webinar series
and so my team and i run the hemp
germplasm repository which is similar to
a library but for seeds and the first
goal of our work is to help protect the
genetic diversity of hemp and our second
goal is to make a lot of different types
of hemp available for science
and so these seeds can be requested by
plant scientists plant breeders and
educators and we believe that these
seeds can be useful to answer all sorts
of questions
and we hope that this work allows
universities companies farmers and
everyone else to benefit from a thousand
percent potential uses of him
during this work we've met so many
interesting and dynamic people across
the world of hemp and we wanted to
present them to you so we teamed up with
our friends at cornell university to
present them to you today so i want to
give a huge thanks to george sack gemma
osborne and kim paul but most of all i'm
thrilled to present our speaker today dr
daniela vergara
dr daniela vergara is an evolutionary
biologist data analyst educator
scientific writer and public speaker in
addition to our multiple publications
she founded and directs a non-profit
organization the agricultural genomics
foundation
which aims to make hemp and cannabinoid
science available to a broad public
dr vergara has been part of scientific
teams at private companies including
steep hill
and a biotech company called front range
biosciences
through agf
dr vergara educates the public about
science data analysis statistics
evolutionary biology and genomics dr
vergara is also an international
consultant and policy advisor and has
advised companies in the us and latin
america
additionally she has worked as an expert
witness for multiple legal cases in the
u.s and abroad dr vergara is a
scientific writer in both spanish and
english and has translated her
scientific work in spanish for a broad
public and hispanic countries
and so before we begin i ask that as you
think of questions for dr vergara
throughout the presentation please put
them in the q a tab and anything written
in the chat tab will not be looked at in
the q a at the end so please put your
questions in throughout the presentation
and without further ado present you uh
take us away dr vergara
thank you very very much tony for the
very nice presentation and thank you for
the organizers i am going to so thank
you very much uh i am daniela vergara
i'm the emerging crop specialist at
cornell
um
so
uh this is my email my um
website my twitter if you want to
contact me
so as uh tony was saying
i was part of the university of colorado
boulder i still am a lecturer there i
teach a class for
the broad public for it through
continuing education if anyone wants to
take it
i am the co-founder of the cannabis
genomic research initiative which is our
group at cu boulder that aims to study
the cannabis genome and i co-founded the
agricultural genomics foundation which
is a non-profit organization that i
currently direct that aims on bringing
science cannabis science to abroad
public and right now i'm part of the
cornell cooperative extension
so if you looked at the schedule today
for 20 lucky me i was scheduled to give
a talk on hemp diversity and genetics
and due to my background the first thing
that i thought was to talk about the
cannabis
genotype however today is the birthday
of this paper that got published last
year so it's one year since i published
this paper so i wanted to talk about
this paper that deals with the phenotype
but you know the talk was on hemp
diversity and genetics so i needed to
talk about the genotype but in my
opinion one of the reasons why we study
the genome which is the whole
conglomerate of dna all of the
collections of letters in a genome right
each of us has a genome cannabis also
has a genome each plant has a genome so
i wanted to talk about the genotype and
one of the reasons we study the genome
is to relate it to the phenotype
so today i'm going to be talking about
the kind of xenotype and phenotype
and i want to let you know that my talk
is going to be a little graph heavy but
i'm going to try my best to explain each
of the graphs
and i want to start with acknowledging
all of my collaborators from all over
the place leafly the agricultural
genomics foundation csu pueblo cu
boulder of course which uh is a place
where i produced all of the data that
i'm going to show you today
and of course front range biosciences
where i worked for two years
and my talk is going to have three
different parts i'm going to talk about
the cannabis genome the cannabinoid
genes the terpene genes
and how each of these relates to the
phenotype
and i'm going to start with a take home
message
when
in the industry they tell you about
sativa and indica
be skeptical
so i'm going to start with the cannabis
genome
so cannabis is an angiosperm plant so
it's a plant that produces flowers it is
part of the cannabis of the family
was described by linnaeus in 1753
cannabis is dioecious so males and
females are in different plants kind of
like us right we have males and females
in different individuals males have an x
on a y chromosome like us
and females on x and x chromosome 2x
chromosomes there's also monicious
individuals so monitors individuals um
produce both males and female flowers
and they have undifferentiated
chromosomes which means that the they're
not like the x and the y but the
chromosomes those themselves are not
different from each other and apparently
um
in these monitors individuals part of
the chromosome is similar to the female
chromosome at least a part of the
chromosome is
and cannabis is diploid right so uh it
inherits like us
one set of chromosomes from mom and one
from dad right so
part of the chromosomes come from that
half of the chromosomes from that and
half from mom
the genome size in cannabis females have
approximately 818 megabase pairs so
818 million letters in the genome
the males have 843 million letters so
the genome of the males is larger than
that of the females because the y
chromosome is larger and in fact the y
chromosome in cannabis is the largest of
all of the genome and again it has 10
chromosomes um nine of them autosomes so
nine of them are not related to sex
chromosomes and then it has an x and the
y
so when we sequence a genome when we
take all of the letters of of of the
genome of the dna and we transcribe them
we have to break them up into little
pieces
and then we have to put them back
together bioinformatically
kind of like putting together a puzzle
right so ideally
when we have something that is called a
genome assembly
we would have
um nine autosomes so nine chromosomes
nine pieces that are not related to the
sex chromosomes and then the sex
chromosomes so in total we would like 11
total pieces with the x and the y right
nine autosomes plus x and y
with the
843 million base pairs
and indeed right now
that is where we are more or less thanks
to grassland collaborators from 2018 in
their pre-print and then later in 2021
we definitely have
nine autosomes so we have nine chunks of
of dna
and we have one sex chromosome we still
we are still lacking the y chromosome
um but we still have 200 pieces that we
don't know where they go
right
so uh we're very close of having a very
good assembly and brussels assembly is a
very good assembly
and this is how it looks like we have
chromosome one two three four five six
seven eight nine and the x chromosome
right we're still lacking the y
chromosome
and we not only have one assembly right
we have multiple assemblies i think that
right now we have between 13 to 15
assemblies that are publicly available
here in this uh slide i'm showing nine
of them right so nine individuals right
nine nine individuals so we have an
individual purple kush vinola jamaican
lion pineapple banana baba kush cs-10
which is the one that grass assembled
the one that i was just talking about
kanatonic carmanola uso31 from csu
pueblo i'm not sure if they're already
publicly available but i'm sure they
will be soon and this um supposedly wild
um
assembly that is also in very good state
so i think that these two cs10 and the
wild one uh we don't really know if
there's wild cannabis that's why it's
wild but that's what they say um
these two are the ones that are in in
the best shape so here i am showing nine
of the 13 or 15 assemblies that we have
available
so when we look at the relationship
between cannabis varieties cannabis
strains
we uh see something like this this is
called a splits tree graph
each of these lines is a strain
the closer you are in this graph the
more of the genome you share so if my
son and i were in this graph we would be
very close to each other because we
share a lot of our genome
so each of this line is a strain i'm
showing here the relationship between
approximately 300 different varieties
300 different strains
this thread-like structure in the middle
is the part of the genome that everyone
shares so it's the part the ancestral
part of the genome
and depending on how you divide this
graph you more or less see these three
groups this is how we divided this graph
and we can see here the broadleaf
marijuana types the narrow leave
marijuana types and the hemps
the brow leaves on the narrow leaves the
broth leaves in purple the narrow leaves
in blue these two are used in medical
and recreational settings while the
hemps are used in industrial settings
and i want to clarify something
these hemps for industrial settings this
group that we see here are the ones that
are used for fiber or for oil
so these guys over here are not
necessarily the ones that have i mean
usually they have less than 0.3 percent
thc but the the government coined the
same hem for anything that has less than
0.3 percent thc and there are some
individuals that are not necessarily
hemp that are actually low thc marijuana
individuals that even though they have
less than 0.3 thc they fall
in these categories over here in this
graph when we look at the genome
now when we look at these nine
assemblies that i just showed you
these assemblies also fall into some of
these groupings so we have for example
purple kush and pineapple banana baba
kush that are part of the broad leaves
finola carmanola and uso31 that are part
of the hemps jamaican lion and catatonic
that are part of the narrow leaves and
then we have these two csn
and the wild one that are hybrids cs10
indeed is a hybrid between a hemp
and a marijuana type
and finola and purple crush i want to
say these were the first two assemblies
that we had available they were
published in 2011 by a group a canadian
group led by jonathan page
and then in 2019 they improved these
assemblies as well
when we look at the variation in the
nuclear genome and these are preliminary
results
we have in this graph we have our three
groups the broad leaves the hamster
narrow leaves and we have in the y-axis
which is our vertical axis we have
diversity
when we look at the diversity in
cannabis we more or less see that it has
approximately two to three percent
nucleotide diversity this is a measure a
measurement of genomic diversity and
this doesn't mean much
but when we compare it to other species
like bonobos chimpanzees humans
domesticated corn
we can see that all of these species
have less than one percent diversity so
cannabis has
approximately two to three percent more
diversity than any of these species
and we can see that as well in the
phenotype
these are leaves from different strains
from different varieties and we can see
that the color varies the number of
leaflets varies the size varies and the
leaves
all of these leaves are very different
from each other but the plants
themselves are also very different
the height the colors the branching
and of course
the variety of compounds that cannabis
produces cannabinoids depending on how
you count them can be up around the
hundreds also terpenes um and flavonoids
there's a bunch of different compounds
and of course the plant can be used for
multiple purposes
um the fiber can be used for rope for
paper the oil can be used in personal
products hemp seeds are edible it can be
used for biofuel
for clothing and of course for medicine
in the industry we're used to see these
two names indica sativa
and then um
you have that the indicas uh are
supposed to have dense um
dense buds and the plants are short and
the leaves are bushy and then the
sativas are tall and the leaves are thin
um but
when we look at leaf shape
i'm gonna be showing these type of
graphs
several times throughout the talks these
are called principal component analysis
graphs and these are a dimensionality
reduction graph so we are basically
taking a bunch of variation and showing
it in two dimensions
principal component one in the
horizontal axis the x-axis and principal
component 2 in the vertical the y-axis
and in this case we are showing the
variation in leaf shape
okay so we have different points in
these leaves these points are called
landmarks we have different dots in
these leaves and if you are in this side
of the graph you have a squat leaf and
your leaflets are pointing out
if you're in this side of the graph you
have more of an elongated leaf and your
leaflets are pointing in
and between these two principal
components of all of the variation right
between these two we're showing more
we're explaining more than 80 of the
variation which is pretty high
females here are the circles males are
the squares
and if we had differences between sexes
in leaf shape we would expect for
example that the males are in this side
of the graph and they have a squat leaf
and the females are in this other side
of the graph and they have an elongated
leaf or perhaps the other way around
where the females are in this side of
the graph and have a squat leaf and the
males in this other side of the graph
with an elongated leaf
but what we see
is that there is no correlation
whatsoever between females and males and
the leaf shape
so you can be a male and have a squat
leaf or you can be a female and have a
squat leaf that has no relationship
whatsoever between sex and leaf shape
and in fact we see that leaf shape has
no relationship with height no
relationship with branches and no
relationship with a bunch of other
traits that we measure stock diameter
number of nodes pdo length um but count
it has no relationship this is this is
all data from birthday paper
and that is probably due to
recombination recombination is this
wonderful process that um sexual
individuals undergo we have again a
chromosome from dad and a chromosome
from mom and then a chunk of the
chromosome swaps so we get a chunk of
the chromosome from mom and that's
chromosome and etc right recombination
kind of looks like this it's not just
one little chunk but there's multiple
places where these chromosomes combine
and thanks to recombination we have a
bunch of variation and thanks to
recombination we differ from our
siblings right it's one of the ways in
where where we differ from our siblings
and maybe we share i don't know hair
color or
the shape of our eyes but we are
different from our siblings and
recombination is one of the reasons
and thanks to recombination we have you
know um red hair with blue eyes brown
hair with blue eyes blonde hair with
blue eyes and so on it's a it's a great
way to shuffle jeans around and to
create
novel combinations
so when they tell you that indicas are
tall and have this particular leaf shape
and sativas or sativas are short
whatever it is
be skeptical because all of these traits
can be shuffled around
especially all of these compounds
because cannabis again produces a bunch
of different compounds
which leads me to the second part of my
talk about cannabinoid genes
but to conclude this first part
cannabis has a lot of genomic variation
a lot of phenotypic variation
a bunch of these phenotypic traits are
not correlated to each other can be
shuffled around and broken by
recombination
perhaps many different combinations are
possible through breeding right many
different combinations that we do not
see yet
and the genome assemblies still need a
lot of work we have very good assemblies
uh but we still do not have um a good
assembly of the y chromosome or of the
monitors chromosomes
so now i'm going to start talking about
the cannabinoid genes
okay so cannabinoid genes so this graph
is a very important graph uh i've shown
it in multiple talks i want to clarify
something this is just the last the last
snippet of a huge biochemical pathway
right this is just the last step of this
huge biochemical pathway
when we talk about cannabinoid genes
we're talking about the genes that code
for these enzymes these three synthesis
right i'm gonna talk about three uh
cannabinoids of the multiple
cannabinoids that kind of this produces
and those are thca cbda and cbca
so these enzymes are proteins that
perform a job they do something in this
case this synthesis these enzymes take
cbga so cannabidiolic acid
and convert it into either thca
cbda or cbca
now
from this pink side up all of this
happens inside of the plant
and when we heat these compounds up when
we heat them up they turn into thc cbd
and cbc but this is outside of the plant
right so through heat that's why baking
vaping smoking we heat them up and they
turn into the neutral forms so the
neutral forms right tetrahydrocannabinol
or cannabidiol they lose this cooh right
they go into the aesthetic form into the
neutral form and again this happens
outside of the plant these neutral forms
are the ones that interact mostly with
our endocannabinoid system
however there is some evidence that the
acidic forms also interact with the
endocannabinoid system
but uh um but in any case we have that
these three enzymes use the same
precursor molecule they use cbga
so under that definition
these three enzymes could be considered
promiscuous enzymes because they are
using the same precursor molecule
now
when i was an undergrad i was taught
that enzymes are very specific
but this is not the case of these
enzymes at least apparently it's not the
case in general but at least if not of
these enzymes we know
that these enzymes in vitro and this is
thanks to a paper circle at all 2018
they show
that these enzymes can produce up to
eight different compounds
including each other's compounds so in
other words thca synthesis can produce a
little bit of cbda cbda synthase a
little bit of cbca
cbca thca and so on so these enzymes can
be promiscuous and can be sloppy
okay
so um i want to define something a gene
is in a location in our chromosomes
right so this is the same location for
mom's chromosome and for that chromosome
and uh so it's a locus right so when
we're talking about a locus is a
specific location and an allele is a
form of a gene and in this case mom or
that could have the same allele the same
form of the gene or they could differ
and at the beginning we thought that if
dad had both thca and cbda so if that
was heterozygous and mom was also
heterozygous then the offspring one
quarter would have thca two quarters
would produce both compounds and then
one quarter would produce cbda
right
so we thought that this was a one locus
two allele type of thing it was the same
gene that had two different forms thca
and cbda
and that's where we have this type 1
type 2 type 3 right type 1 high thca
type 2 both thca and cbda and then type
3 cbda
and it wasn't until 2015 with a really
good paperwork by george weinblein
where they found
one individual they made a cross between
a marijuana type and a hemp type which
is our cs10 assembly
um so they made this cross
and there was one individual that
recombined they had a less than 100
individuals i think it was around the
60s or the 70s and there was one
individual that got the thca and the
cbda
loci the one individual recombined and
thanks to that one individual we found
that these were two different genes that
were in close proximity approximately
one sunny morgan apart so one
recombination event apart so um thanks
to this recombination event we now found
that indeed these were two different
genes that that were in very close
proximity and that it was really hard to
tear them apart because they were in
close proximity again when we used to
play chain when we were kids or maybe
you still play chain right now i'm not
sure but when we used to do that it is
harder to break people apart when
they're close together it is easier to
break them apart when they're far apart
that's the same case as cbda and thca
they were very close together and
therefore it was very hard to tear them
apart
um so thanks to this one individual this
recombinant
grass i used the same population
with this paper uh this is a paper that
i was just talking about uh george
weinblain is also part of this um of
this publication
and this is a very busy figure but what
i want to take uh what what i want you
to take from this figure is that these
genes indeed are very similar to each
other this shows the relationship this
part of the figure shows a relationship
between the individuals they're very
similar to each other and they are in
very close proximity in the genome all
of these cannabinoid genes are in very
close proximity in the genome
and this is what we see in their map we
see that all of the cannabinoid genes
are in this chromosome
so at least the genes with major effects
the genes that have the most effects in
cannabinoid production are on this on
this chromosome but there are multiple
genes all over the genome
that are related to cannabinoid
production
then in 2019 we had a paper where we
discussed
that all of the individuals have
all of
the cannabis varieties differ in the
number of cannabinoid genes
all of the different strains have
different number of genes and that this
um
variation in copy number in these genes
could have associations to cannabinoid
production
and indeed when we look at the different
assemblies we can see that all of the
assemblies differ in the number of genes
right and we have for example this wild
one that has eight copies of cannabinoid
genes and jamaican lion can that
apparently has up to 32.
i also recommend this other paper that
talks about um cannabinoid genes
bamboozled and trans published in 2021
that talks about the evolution and the
origin of these genes this is another
must read paper
so now we know that this thca cbda being
one gene being one locus two alleles is
is not the case
so when we look at the genes the
cannabinoid genes from all of these
different assemblies
and we look at the relationship again i
want to make it clear that these are
nine individuals these are nine
individuals that i'm showing in this
slide
that these nine individuals differ in
the number of cannabinoid genes but when
we look at the relationship of all of
the genes from these nine individuals
this is what we see and i'm not gonna go
in depth into this graph but what i want
you to take from this graph is the
following
there's a bunch of genes related to cbca
production
despite cbca being produced in very low
quantities
there are some genes related to thca
production
and most of the individuals that have
thca are marijuana type cannabis
there's a bunch of genes that we don't
know what they're doing we have no idea
and every single one of the assemblies
has a gene
that falls into this category
in this unknown category and there's
some genes related to cbda production uh
some hemp have cvda some marijuana types
have cbda
so again uh something that really caught
my attention was for example kanatonic
again this is one individual of
kanatonic right so i'm drawing a bunch
of conclusions based on one individual
however canatonic in the industry it's
sold as a one-to-one strain so it's
supposed to have one cbd and thc in
equal proportions
however hanatonic has
a truncated cbd a gene so an incomplete
cbd a gene and an incomplete thca gene
so it makes us wonder
right if that one individual can atonic
if there's other genes that may be
coming together to form this cannabinoid
phenotype right so we have then
two genes or multiple genes that come
together to form the phenotype and in
biology we call that epistasis
where genes interact to form a phenotype
um so perhaps all of these genes
are interacting to form the phenotype
right so what does the phenotype tells
us so this is a paper that we that is in
impress right now with my collaborators
from leafly
here in the vertical axis the y axis we
have cannabinoid concentration
and here in the x-axis we have the
different cannabinoids and i want so
this figure is a little biased because
this is the cannabis found in
dispensaries so of course the cannabis
found in dispensaries have high thc
and we are not taking into account
cannabis from
uh from hemp right we do not have hemp
for fiber or for oil
it's not represented in dispensaries but
the cannabis from dispensaries um we
have a lot of thc up the median is
between 15 to 20 maybe 18
some individuals produce a lot of cbd
um there's some cbg but really uh most
of the cannabinoids are negligible right
uh again it's interesting that cbc is
produced in very low quantities despite
there being a bunch of genes related to
cbc production
and if we look at the relationship
between thc concentration in the x-axis
the horizontal axis and cbd in the
y-axis the vertical axis we see that
there's some individuals that produce a
lot of thc and very little cbd some
individuals that produce a lot of cbd
and little thc and some individuals in
between
now if we look at leaf shape and
cannabinoids right
so again males are the squares females
are the circles and if we look at leaf
shape and cannabinoids perhaps we would
be expecting two groups right that maybe
these individuals over here have a
particular chemotype and have a squat
leaf these individuals over here have
another chemotype and an elongated leaf
or maybe even four different groups with
four different chemotypes and four
different leaf shapes
but that's not what we see
we see that leaf shape has no
correlation whatsoever with cannabinoid
content so you can have high thc and
have an elongated leaf or high thc and a
squat leaf that has no relationship
whatsoever
so again when they give you uh when they
tell you that indicas are one-way and
broad leaves and high cannabinoids and
sativas are another way be skeptical
however
we do see uh between cannabinoids here
in the x-axis in the horizontal axis and
terpenes we do see that there is a
correlation so the more cannabinoids you
produce the more terpenes you produce
now this correlation is not very strong
but it is significant
which makes us wonder whether there are
some genes that are related to both
cannabinoid and terpene production
and i can think about some for example
trichome density or trichome number
right we know that in the trichomes is
where we have the production of all of
these compounds
most of the trichomes are abundant in in
female flowers so perhaps if you have a
lot of trichomes or if you have big
trichomes you're gonna produce both
um a lot of cannabinoids and a lot of
terpenes
and
zagarandera saguaro in 2019 they do
suggest
that there is an interaction between
genes that there is a network between
genes that are acting together to
produce the cannabinoid and the terpene
phenotype and this is another must-read
paper in my opinion
which leads me to the last part of my
talk about terpene genes
but to conclude this part
there are many genes related to
cannabinoid production
all of these genes are interacting to
produce a phenotype
that's still a question
individuals differing the number of
cannabinoid genes so there is copy
number variation associated to
cannabinoid production
and uh cannabinoids and other phenotypes
are not related to each other
so tripping genes
and i want to start with this graph
again showing the relationship between
terpenes synthase genes tps
and this is by
my colleagues at front range biosciences
so
something that i want you to see from
this graph is that it appears that
there's many genes related for example
to the production of beta mercy
or to limonene and and beta osimin right
and if we look at this other paper by
boothidal again 2019 i think that 2019
was the year of the 13
so we see that in the different
chromosomes in cannabis
there are multiple genes related to
terpene and cannabinoid production so
all of these genes are scattered
throughout the genome again
supporting that idea from zagar at all
that there are multiple genes acting in
unison to produce this cannabinoid and
disturbing phenotype
so i
talked to you about epistasis where it's
genes interacting
but it but perhaps we also have
cleotropy where we have
one gene that is affecting two different
phenotypes right so the expression of
multiple traits by one gene
so perhaps what's going on with the
terpenes is that for example we have tps
five
that is related to the production of
beta mercy but we also have tps 23 and
tps 12
and perhaps we also have the tps5 is
related to the production of limonene
and beta pinene
and then tps 12 is also related to the
production of osamine
and so on
which is what sagar at all are proposing
so maybe we have between cannabinoids
and terpenes we have cleotrophy and
epistasis in place
genes interacting to produce this
phenotype
so now what does the phenotype tell us
and again this is
a graph
from
our leaflet paper that is only analyzing
the cannabis from dispensaries so it is
a biased sample
but the cannabis from dispensaries this
is what we see in the y-axis the
vertical axis we have total terpene
concentration and here we have all of
the different terpenes and we see that
the cannabis from dispensaries is high
in beta-mercene beta-carophylline and
limonene so if you go
today
at a dispensary it's likely that you can
buy something that has high beta mercy
and beta-carotelline or lemony
now i'm going to show another principal
component analysis graph
here again this is a dimensionality
reduction and each of the dots is an
individual
and
pc1 principle component 1 explains the
most variation then pc2 explains the
next more variation and between these
two in this particular graph between
these two we're explaining about 60
of the variation
which is pretty high
so
we would be expecting that if the sativa
in red and the indica and the hybrid
explain the variation perhaps we would
see something like this right where the
sativas are in a corner um with a
particular chemotype
and the indicas are in another corner
with a particular a chemotype and then
the hybrids are in between
however that's not what we see
what we see is that the sativas and the
indicas and the hybrids do not explain
the chemothe the chemotypic variation
again this is a dimensionality reduction
so we're taking all of the variation in
chemotype and we're showing it in two
different dimensions dc1 and pc2 in this
case
but we see that
it doesn't matter if you're an indie
power a sativa or a hybrid according to
the industry that doesn't say anything
about your chemotype
however
if we partition this same graph
by the most common terpene we see a
different thing
and we can see different clusters we can
see that in this corner we have
individuals that have high beta mercy
right this is the most
prominent terpene
and we can see that over here we have
the individuals that are uh they're high
interpinoline
and then when we take this same graph
and we partition it
using another mathematical algorithm we
can see that it clusters in three
different we can see three different
clusters
one cluster that is high in
cariophylline and limonene here in pink
another cluster here in blue high in
mercedes and pinene and another cluster
here high interpinoline and mercy
so it seems that turkeys are better at
clustering
um cannabis strains
than the industry names
so again when they tell you
that sativas have a particular smell
associated with a particular height with
a particular leaf shape and indicas have
another smell with a particular other
height and another leaf shape
be very very skeptical
so to conclude this part of my talk
there are many genes related to terpene
production
um are all these genes interacting to
produce a terpene phenotype again that
question remains
and terpenes seem to be better at
grouping individuals than industry names
and to conclude my talk overall
there is law there is a lot of
phenotypic and genomic diversity in
cannabis perhaps we can
breed for strains that have not yet been
developed
cannabinoids and terpenes show a mild
correlation it seems that there could be
genes that are affecting both
cannabinoids are highly correlated
between them
and there's multiple genes related to
cannabinoid and terpene production these
genes are scattered throughout the
genome
terpenes are better at grouping strains
than industry names and many important
traits but the cannabis industry are not
related to each other
so again
when they tell you about indica and
sativa be skeptical
and again i want to thank all of my
collaborators from academia and the
industry and i want to give a shout out
today on 420 to all of my friends most
of these are in colorado so i want to
say hi to all of you
and my new friends here in new york
state
and with that visit our website cornell
cooperative extension
and this is my contact information
and i am happy to take any questions
thank you
outstanding daniella thank you so much
for that wonderful talk
yeah that was fantastic
thank you uh first question do the
neutral forms of cannabinoids appear in
the plant in low concentrations
like during storage or drying or in a
warm environment or heating from
overhead lights or the sun
yes they do
yes definitely yeah we we do see that um
the neutral forms uh accumulating very
low quantities you do have to heat them
up for them to to uh accumulating in
higher quantities but yes
you do see a little bit yeah
awesome
next question
um what is your opinion on the use of
feminized seeds in the cultivation and
breeding of cannabis
um
has the breeding done by the legacy
market contaminated the cannabis genome
through
breeding with feminized seeds
um that is an interesting question so i
don't know contaminated i wouldn't i
wouldn't say that you know when you're
breeding you're choosing for a
particular trait so i i wouldn't say
that it has contaminated now
um
i okay so feminized it's a water
feminized seeds so something that i
didn't talk about in cannabis is that
when you
stress the plants so that means that you
could apply particular hormones or that
you can change light regimes there are
certain genes that are turned on and you
can have a female and you can uh make
that female produce pollen so then you
have a female that has two x chromosomes
and that female produces pollen and you
take that pollen from that female and
self fur fertilize her
or
fertilize another female friend
so then the seeds that are produced do
not have a white chromosome right so
you're you're assuring that those seeds
do not have a y chromosome they only
have x chromosomes that's why they're
called feminized seeds
now
several things
you don't know whether indeed
those individuals those seeds whether
they're not going to have the
possibility of producing pollen if you
stress them out or if you apply hormones
perhaps they do and in fact many of the
feminized seeds there is a low
percentage of individuals that do
produce pollen
so that regarding feminized seeds i
think that feminized seeds are great if
they work for you why not
um
now the legacy growers i mean the legacy
growers have a legacy and they have the
word legacy attached to them for a
reason
um i think that in general the breeding
in cannabis has not been
a very
um
very stringent for many reasons right
because cannabis has been illegal for so
long that people have been breeding in
their closets and their basement
literally right so it's really hard when
you don't have enough space in your
closet or in your basement to do
um
good breeding to to to breed for
multiple individuals you you don't have
space you cannot you know grow
300 individuals 500 individuals that you
need when you're doing
reading
so um so in that sense you know i i i do
think that legacy growers have worked
with the things that they have in hand
and that they have done they have done
really good things with the
possibilities that they have available i
think
awesome
next question
were you able to or do you believe it's
possible to accurately determine
cannabinoid levels in a plant
marijuana or hemp using only leaves
cannabinoid levels
i don't know i think that you need the
flour but what i do know is that the
ratios
of cannabinoids um if you do it even
when the plant is little the ratios do
not change that much
through time and i'm not sure i know
that the leaves you know and especially
sugar leaves those have a lot of
trichomes so they are gonna show
cannabinoids but i don't know if they're
gonna show as much cannabinoids as a
flower perhaps the ratios are gonna be
the same but the amounts are gonna
differ
great um
another question
um
can you speak about um
variation in flowering time and would
you speculate that shorter flowering
times may have some relationship to seed
reuteralis
flowering time oh that's
very smart's baby
so um can i speak about flowering time
we know that there is variation in
flowering time right we know that there
is
uh
yeah that there is variation in
flowering time and we know that
depending on where you are or how many
plants you want to grow in a given time
you may want to play with flowering time
you know if you want to grow
several
a if you want to grow
in in one season you want to grow
multiple plants you you want to play
with flowering time
rudor alice
it seems like rudor ellis is a thing we
still don't know you know like up north
in siberia um it seems that it is a
thing again we don't know whether
there's wild cannabis
um we don't know whether the cannabis
that it's found out is feral you know it
escaped or if it's indeed wild we still
do not know whether they're wild
populations and it seems that the ritual
this is a thing indeed you see these
plants that are shorter and that out of
flower
and so they do not obey the light cues
right so usually cannabis starts
flowering when it senses that the light
is is
is um
diminishing in the during the fall
months but um
but yeah rudor alice it seems that
there's some plan there is out of
flowering plants there are out of
flowering plants now whether or not
those jeans are coming from rudor alleys
or not whether those genes indeed are
associated to these plants i think that
that's a different question but you know
we could answer that question if we have
sequencing of all of these ruralist
plants and if we have good phenotyping
data
we could answer those questions
great
um
another question many questions um
if you color the genetic pca by terpene
chemotype is there any clustering there
if i color
the
terpene pca by genetic phenotype oh
yeah the genetic pca by terpene
variation yeah
so what was that genetic pc a
are they talking about the
the um
are they talking about the the split
street graph
or because i didn't i don't think that i
showed a genomic pca but okay so
um i don't know i didn't do that
but
so far
i am showing here different data sets
right in this talk i show different data
sets
now
in an ideal world we would have
all
phenotypes from each of the data sets
and all genomics from the other data
sets for example with the leafly data
set
we have a bunch of you know tens of
thousands of of chemotypes that we had
available thanks to leafly
but we did not have the genotype of
those individuals right those those were
actually
six different labs across the us a lab
in florida another in michigan another
in california in washington
that people go to those labs to measure
their
their cannabinoids under terpenes so we
do not have um pairing genetics data
sets to for for them
that would be a really interesting
question though right yeah
and expensive as well
of course everything's expensive
um
another question kind of related so you
mentioned um what where the labs were
that generated that uh cannabinoid
interpreting data uh do you know where
the dispensaries were were they in the
same states as where the labs were
uh
i
don't know i know that the leafly people
do know i
i
i was really excited to be part of that
analysis because
um
it's one of the biggest uh terpene
cannabinoid chemotypes data sets that
we've analyzed and it was one of the
best collaborations that i've had so far
and uh
the four of us will
would meet on fridays every two weeks
and it was a great collaboration
i know that there's six labs independent
labs in six different places in the u.s
i was positively surprised by that data
set because the labs were very
consistent with each other
um the measurements were very consistent
with each other so i was positively
surprised
um
so
uh
i
don't know if leafly is gonna make
available the data or if the labs made
available to leafly the data from the
dispensaries or from the people which i
actually think
that it
it's not important right i mean what's
important is that one the labs were very
consistent and and congratulation
cannabis industry that despite
still being federally illegal and still
having so much restrictions the labs are
doing great job at measuring these
chemotypes so first and second um
i think that that gives us um
you know it gives us peace of mind that
there are labs that that you can take
your your your kind of your cannabis and
they're gonna do a good job at measuring
it so i don't i think that that's
independent of of who the dispensary was
or whether that was i don't know
purple kush or um or blue dream that
doesn't matter we have the data of the
cannabinoids and terpenes that these
strains had and it's ten thousands of
tens of thousands of strains
so we were able to to measure a bunch of
and do a bunch of different statistics
and it was a very um
thorough statistic analysis that we did
with that
awesome um another question
uh is there evidence that terpenes or
groups of terpenes are responsible for
the sativa hybrid indica effects that
are persisting in industry marketing
no and that's what i just showed right
so let me share my screen again
so um
this is this is the data that i just
showed that
um
you know like the industry says that
um
so the industry says that
indica sativa hybrid you have this
particular characteristics which are not
correct right we don't see that with the
genome we see that in the conceptiva
hybrid they are not
related in any sort of genotype right
and we don't see it with the phenotype
either whether we look at phenotypes
like leaf shape or height or
branching or nodes or
males or females or terpenes or
cannabinoids so that indica sativa
hybrid is
i don't know what the basis is for that
indicative hybrid like it's kind of like
saying you know like kind of relating
like okay
um
you
if you are blue eyed you're always gonna
be blonde like that has nothing to do
with each other or or if you are tall
you're always gonna have brown eyes that
has nothing to do with each other those
traits are broken by recombination so if
we see this graph right we would be
expecting i mean this is my my made
graph like it's not as pretty as what we
actually really did but if we would be
expecting if the indica sativa hybrid
if it were true we would be expecting
that the indicas would cluster with each
other and the sativas with each other
and maybe the hybrids are are somewhere
in between
but that's not what we see
we see that the names are not related
whatsoever with the type of compounds
but we do see that we can cluster these
strains based on uh the most common
terpene or groups of terpenes right here
in this graph um when we do this
clustering analysis we do see this clear
partition
and this clear partition
is
we name the cluster one cluster two and
cluster three but you can call it i
don't know uh mary jane and john right
um these three clusters do have
particular terpenes which are the most
abundant terpenes so terpenes are better
at
at clustering than the indica sativa
hybrid
i don't know if that was clear
awesome
um
another question
what do you think are the technical or
computational bottlenecks for completing
the whole cannabis genome
the technical or computational i don't
think that there are any technical or
computational
um bottlenecks i think that the
bottlenecks are money
because you require someone that knows a
lot of bioinformatics
and uh
and more money
to sequence
a really good y chromosome with long
reads you know like a biotype of thing
long reads and very high coverage so i
would sequence a bunch of males with
very long reads
um with very high coverage in both back
bio and corrected with the lamina
illumina so so that's
some chunk of money and then you would
need a lot of people good people that
that have really good bioinformatics
skills that have a lot of time to
dedicate to this to do that i think that
one of the reasons why the y chromosome
is not finished it's because it's hard
it's huge
and it has a bunch of repetitive content
so it's really hard you know like you
have blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah it's really hard to put it
together it's really hard to build a
puzzle so i think that that it needs a
lot of time a lot of money to do it
okay i think um
[Music]
we'll do one more question and this will
kind of bring us right back to where we
started here how do you think that we
prefer uh preserve the diversity in the
cannabis genome so that we don't lose
possible therapeutic therapeutic effects
on you know other other diverse
characteristics that may be present in
the plant but have been overlooked in
the past
preserve the cannabis genome well i
think that that's what zach and tony are
trying to do right i think that that's
why the usda and that repository is so
important because
that's the entire point right preserving
all of these different strains all of
these different varieties
um
in order to have a big a good library
that represents the variation that's out
there and i remember that when zac and i
met
that was one of his questions which i
pondered
and i discussed with multiple people
like how do we know that we are indeed
having a good representation of what's
out there and if indeed those
preliminary results are right that
cannabis has twice or three times as
much variations as humans at least
how many individuals do we need to have
in that repository that are
representative of what's out there
and what i recommend to people is you
know keep seeds and then if you see a
fair little guy and you see a ditch weed
do not ditch it you know it may have
really good characteristics and and yeah
so so i think or or at least you know
try to give it to sak
somehow
you know i don't know what are the laws
and the regulations with the usda but
but um but
that is why it sucks and tony's job is
is so crucial and so important
so
just very very briefly i i just
want to speak on everyone's behalf
because i think it's true that was a
fascinating mind-blowing informative
talk daniela and you are
a treasure and thank you for your time
that was
one of the highlights of the entire
seminar series
so thank you again um
and to the audience
we are
very interested in genetic diversity and
conserving it for all of the reasons
that dr vergara
illuminated please reach out to tony and
i if you think you may hold some genetic
diversity that we can conserve in the
long term
um
i just was curious your vision of five
ten years for hemp genetics
20 years what could that look like
mine
yes
oh my god that is such a good question
uh first and such a good question on 420
please have a happy 420 everyone but um
you know i've been thinking about the
question now that i'm dealing my job now
requires me to work with with people and
with farmers
and
i am gonna say something that may not be
that popular among people but um
i think that big companies and big
corporations which i'm not gonna name i
am not against them i think that many of
them have done really good science
however i do think that there is a
disconnect with what they propose and
what the public gets
i think that people need to be educated
about genomics not because you're all
going to become genomic system buying
from bioinformaticians but because when
you understand that you make
better choices and educated educated
choices
i think that it's really important to
know who is going to have this data
gmos
are an excellent choice in my opinion
gmos and vaccines are kind of like
mind-blowing like you know like a movie
you know like i i think about it and
it's like wow
and it's going to happen but it's who is
going to handle that data who is going
to have access to that data is it going
to be few stakeholders which is what
we've seen so far or is it going to be
part of the public realm right like are
we all gonna have access to that and i
think that that is really important and
i think that cannabis right now
is in that point right there's many
companies that are looking for example
flowering time jeans there are several
companies that have their eyes on
flowering time jeans um who is gonna
hold those patents and those
technologies is it gonna be two three
companies or is it gonna be all of us so
that's something that i hope that
cannabis differs from other important
crops
maybe a romantic way to end the
presentation
so i think we'll leave it at that thank
you so much george and tony and everyone
that's contributed to this but once
again um
thanks again dr vergara
thank you
thank you thank you very much
um
i think we could have kept you in here
for another hour just answering
questions yeah really were they i'm
looking at the queue and they um
where in the constantine where hybrid
david provided
or where the products came from these
are really good questions as a follow-up
what is the thought of the difference oh
i know my viewing test was here oh i
know some people
so as a follow-up so from matthew
windest what is thought to cause the
difference in effect
i mean um i don't know the difference in
effect
because we have so many compounds
interacting with each other
that enterage effect is a very in my
opinion it's a really um
a really interesting hypothesis and i
think that you have different ratios of
compounds and multiple of them so if
they're all interacting with each other
and besides we don't know you know if
the smoke that you the the joint that
you smoked today is it gonna have the
same effects as if you do it tomorrow
right or is it gonna have the same
effect on me as on you we don't we don't
know that so those are really important
interesting questions were the
indicative or hybrid data provided by
the dispensaries where the products came
from
yes this data was provided to leafly
from the dispensaries or from the people
so yes yeah those were the names that
the industry provided does the
biosynthetic pathway help explain the
correlation of terpenes and cannabinoids
suck spangler i've seen foxpangler
before um
yeah i think so right because they're
using the same precursor molecule so and
then cannabinoids and terpenes at some
point they come from the same
biochemical pathway right several steps
above they do come from the same
biochemical pathway so yes i do think
that they do explain the correlation
between terpenes and cannabinoids at
some point but there are multiple genes
that are interacting right
um so okay what other can you measure
the amount of cannabinoids within the
hires for industrial hemp production
that would be really interesting to do
to measure the amounts of of industrial
hemp however
because it is not required then
people do not do it right if you're
growing it for fiber
or for oil you're just going to measure
thc to understand whether it's compliant
with the law but do you really care
about the other terpenes however i do
think that that would really complement
the scientific story
anjali angeline
are the terpenes synthesis genes linked
with the thc or cbda genes when you show
the pc analysis
so for that pc analysis because we had
so many
high
thc
um strains we used those
right because they were from
dispensaries and people go to
dispensaries for high thc mostly
um
thomas are there any studies and
collections completed in progress on
american feral hemp
uh
no but we can start one i think for a
sack did you just there was one that
came out like two days ago on nebraska
feral home you're right
you're right yes on nebraska feral hemp
so yeah they are there are
uh do the number of cannabinoid genes
affect the amount of cannabinoids of
plant pollutants so 8 equals x and 32
equals versus x
we didn't find that we did find that
there were some positive correlations
between the number of copies and some
negative correlations so so we don't
know for thc for example we found the
positive correlation but for c with d we
found the negative correlation so that's
a good question do you consider doing a
pc analysis among phenotypes of flower
and its correlation to cannabinoids
quality and quantity since that genetic
plays important role in specific genes
are expressed yes but i don't know if a
pc analysis would be the right way to do
that i mean i love pc analysis because
they're so versatile but
but anyway
um
i think i answered many of these
questions
i was curious
sorry here we go um
i was fascinated by your non your
statistically significant correlation
between terpenes and cannabinoids
and that could be an example of a
cleotropic or epistatic effect
potentially do you think that could also
be explained by agricultural conditions
second healthy plants produce more
secondary metabolites in general
that's a great question
that's i mean
the
that's a great question i think that it
could be however
there are many terpenes that are
produced
when you are not in the best conditions
where you're being eaten right
so so in certain conditions you may not
want to produce you're producing those
terpenes because you're actually
stressed you know like you're getting
eaten by a worm so you're producing
those terpenes so
i do think that you know like we know
that light plays a crucial role in the
production at least of cannabinoids
so perhaps when you have really good
light you produce more cannabinoids and
therefore more terpenes
um we also know
again i i would like to know more about
the genes related to
to trichomes right if you have bigger
trichomes or more trichomes are you also
having more abundant cannabinoids and
terpenes
but i do think that measuring those
uh environmental effects and having a
constant environment in order to do this
i think that that would be crucial
that's that's a great question i think
any work on a cannabis pen genome
sorry
do you know of any work on the cannabis
pan genome
well that's what people are
suggesting right that that's where we're
going
right again i think it it's important
for academic institutions to be involved
in that and to
try to
have students be involved with data
collections but but yeah i think that
that's it's a great way to do i i think
it's it's important to
to have these span genomes yep
well uh thank you for staying a little
extra and you know i i want to talk to
you all day
daniella about this stuff but we should
probably let you go
okay thank you very much i had a lot of
fun
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu